[Music]
hello and welcome to talk to you the
cloud i'm salem amazit clac
consultant at google london today
i'm offering to talk
about code driven infrastructure deployment
on behalf of our favorite company the
fantastic knitting after putting in
place the technical architecture
necessary for rapid
resource provisioning and agile development of
new features the
fantastic knitting teams
realized that too many bugs were slipping into
their code and that rigorous testing
was more than
necessary therefore they needed  a
new test environment
or even several technically
identical to their production environment
so they decided to
fully automate the configuration of a new
environment with google clad diplomate
manager by automating the creation of
resources and services google clad
diplomate manager allows  to
focus on the development  of
the application rather than on
the infrastructure
but what exactly is a complaint manager
it is an
infrastructure deployment service that
automates the creation and management of
google cloud resources
we can create
flexible configuration models  and use them
to create deployments with
various services such as cloud storage
driving in jeans or big red and which are
configured to work together
with a manager's degree the term
infrastructure as a service
makes sense let's start with the
basics first  we will deploy a
development virtual machine to
test an application a configuration
describes all the resources associated with
a single deployment a configuration
is written in ciamel syntax and
lists each of the resources in the
deployment a resource can be
any type of service
available in  google cloud
for example a virtual machine or
even an adre  sse public ip
here is an example of deploying a
virtual machine on google cloud with
a basic configuration and amel which
I called hello world vm and amel
each resource in the configuration
can be
specify as a type the types
can be a type  basic managed by
google a composite type a
type provider or a model imported here it
is a basic type concludes jean
for a virtual machine
after declaring the type of
resources
we must also give it a name
here I  called my virtual machine
hello world
vm then you have to specify the
desired properties for my
virtual machine is for example here the
following configuration file defines an
instance of virtual machines with the
following properties the zone us central
1 f1 type of machine f
a micro  or a persistent disk type
with the
linux debian operating system the
deployment manager will use
this information to create  er an instance
of virtual machines with its
specific properties
here is the g cloud command to run
the deployment using the file
via mail that I just presented
the depressing icloud manager deployment
create
I called this deployment we
now check that the machine  virtual has
started well in the console we go to
the main menu compute as jean
viêt-minh 106 and we can see a
new virtual machine called hello
world
vm this deployment has also created what
is called a manifest a manifest
and a file in  read-only which
describes all the resources in a
deployment in detail diplomat manager
creates the manifest and logs any
errors or
sustained investments during the deployment which
makes the manifest very useful for
troubleshooting
one can view the details of the manifest by
going  in the main menu of the
google cloud console of deployment plans and
managers, select
deploy  ement and the manifest its
sheet with the details of the resources
that have been created
now let's see how to deploy a
complete application thanks to
manager development it is an
application with three components a
round balancers which will receive
user requests  and distribute it
automatically a frontend to
run the application and a backend
to store the data the frontend and
the backend are managers in stat
group which adds additional virtual machines
automatically based on the number
of users
the main configuration file
is  called application dots and hamel
it uses so called
templates to generate a
complete infrastructure supporting the application a
configuration can contain multiple
templates which are basically
parts of the configuration file which
have been reorganized as
reusable blocks indeed  after creating
a model we can  ut reuse it
in other deployments more if it is
necessary to rewrite
configurations share
very similar properties or resources
the same templates can be reused the
templates are much more flexible than
individual configuration files
and are designed to
allow  portability between
deployments a model can be created
with python or jean jacques here we will
use python the front-end
point straw file is a model to create a
group of virtual machines supporting
a frontend the backend point
straw files is a model to create  a
group of virtual machines supporting
a backend they can be reused
in any deployment or
applications that require
similar functions
the elbé dot straw file is a
template to create a batch of balancer
as for the front-end and back-
end templates it can be  reused in
any deployment that
requires the other  e balance r we will now
use first managers to
deploy the application and make it
operational
here is the command to execute the
deployment using the
point hamel application file and the models
that I have just presented I
burst depressing manager deployment
of krayt
j  've called this deployment my fancy
applications we now check that
the application has been deployed in
the console
can in the main menu
competitor jean instant if this group this
and we can see that the magicians this
group this frontend a backend have
been well  created now we check that the
load balancers has been created in the
console we go to the main menu
network services load balancing and we
can see that it has also been created
correctly
do you know what cloud foundations
toolkit is the crowdfunding toolkit
toolkit extends the capabilities of
diplomats manager and gilles cloud
to support the
following creative scenarios  ion update and
deletion of several deployments in
a single operation
graf in china toolkit create or
update deployments in an order
calculated automatically according to
dependencies and also manages
cross-references of deployments including
between projects which avoids coding
hard-coded many settings in
configurations cloud foundation tool kit
also includes a full set
of resource templates ready to
use in production complies with
google best practices for example
if the configuration file at
contains all network resources the
configuration file  b contains
all the instances and cissé contains
the vpn with clouds
you must manually define the order of
deployment of these configurations to
take into account the dependencies between the
resources cloud foundation toolkit
calculates its dependencies automatically
which eliminates the need to define
the deployments manually  here are
several models that are part of
cloud foundations toolkit
for example here is the model to create
a data 7 and a table in big willie
here is a model you need to create a
google cloud storage bucket
here are three example
configuration files with interdependencies
network.com  it specifies a network
firewall point hamel will create
a firewall rule that depends on
the previous network and finally instance point
hamel which will create a virtual machine
itself dependent on the network specified
just before here is the syntax
for using cloud foundations
toolkit crowdfunding toolkit  execute the
actions in the order calculate we
now use cloud foundations toolkit
to create our infrastructure with the
cft krayt command
we have the following result
in this example the network configuration
has no dependency and the
instance firewall configurations
depend on the  network therefore
the network configuration is deployed in
first then the firewall and finally last
years which corresponds to the correct order
this concludes the video of diplomates
manager we have seen that diplomate manager
allows you to have a simplified management of
your infrastructures in google clad a
reproducible
and deterministic deployment process  a model-based solution
all this in an
easy-to-read declarative language that
saves you from developing complex scripts
and allows you to
focus on developing
new features
thank you for your attention and see you soon
[Music]